one of your favorite authors Jack Vance
completed the final volume in his ports
of call series in 2004 he was 87 he says
how impressed are you by that
accomplishment and would you take the
over-under on you beating that mark and
finishing their own series
that's from Michael well you know
writers have written for far longer than
even then I mean Nigel Tranter the great
Scottish historical novelist I think
we're still producing the works right up
until it is mid or late nineties Jack
Williams and my own dear friend and
colleague from New Mexico was in his
late nineties and still still writing
right up to the time of his his death so
you know I I hope to finish the Ice and
Fire series much sort of than that but
then they go on to write many many more
books some set in Westeros and some set
in the wild card universe or a sequel to
fever dream which I've always thought of
doing some ideas my famous unfinished
novel black and white and red all over
I'd like to get back to at some point I
have a an idea that I've been wanting to
write for years about a haunted movie
palace called now showing at the castle
you know I have tons of things I'd like
to do
and life is short unfortunately but I
hope it will be long enough for me to do
to do some of these I have known a few
writers who have retired
I cannot imagine ever retiring I did
writing and being a writer is too much
part of my identity and too much part of
what I am I don't know what I would do
with all that time if I did stop writing
you know play video games or something
like that watch a lot more television
that it seems unlikely to me I've always
told stories whether I could make my
living from it or even when I was a
little kid just making up stories for
the other kids in the neighborhood and I
think I'm gonna continue to do that
until the end Elizabeth and Lisa or
asked how do you presume to know the
inner workings of such various types of
characters from Brienne to Sam well
beyond to damp hair and how are you able
to wrap your head around the thoughts
and motivations of so many characters
well I think the one thing that unites
all of these people is different as they
maybe in terms of age and sex and
religious faith and whatever is that
they all are basically human beings I
write some characters who are like me
although none of them precisely like me
because I was not born into a medieval
feudal society
I write characters who are on a surface
of leaves very unlike me and but in
every case for the motivating emotional
power I have to look inward I think all
writers do that you know the only person
we ever truly know is is ourselves and
our hopes our dreams our fears the
things that haunt us at night so I think
you need empathy and you need to
remember that as different as different
types of people maybe we're all share a
common
humanity and are not ultimately that
different from each other
Susan says of course I'm only partway
through volume 2 after having watched
the HBO series and gotten hooked but his
brand's paralysis mental rather than
physical and thus will he walk again I
don't know if you can answer that
question
well I won't answer a second half of it
but I will say his no as his paralysis
is physical